منذ بدايه الهجوم الروسي على اوكرانيا
كانت بولندا سباقه في تقديم ما لديها في
ترسانتها من ذخائر ودبابات وكذلك نصف ما
لديها من مقاتلات 29 الى الاوكرانيين
لتكون ثاني دوله في حلف الناتو تقدم
طائرات حربيه لكيافه بولندا على الجانب
الاخر
ذهبت مؤخرا لتوقيع على عدد من الصفقات
العسكريه مع الولايات المتحده هذا الامر
جعل مراقبين يرون بانها قريبا ستصبح واحده
من اهم القوه في اوروبا الشرقيه لمناقشه
التطورات العسكريه وكذلك الخطوات التي
اتخذتها بولندا تجاهها دعم اوكرانيا وايضا
تقييم مدى استعداديه الجيش البولندي لاي
تطورات ميدانيه معنا من وارسو الجنرال
جوفسكي نائب رئيس الاركان الاسبق للجيش
البولندي وممثل بولندا السابق في المجلس
العسكري لحلف الناتو اولا السيد اهلا بك
معنا في عسكريتاريا يعني على مدى عام
واكثر قدمت بولندا لاوكرانيا دبابات وكذلك
نصف ما لديها من مقاتلات مايك 29 لماذا كل
هذا الدعم العسكري من بولندا لاوكرانيا
وكذلك مدى تاثير هذا الدعم على الاستعداد
العسكري
في المستقبل
شكرا جزيلا لكم على الاستضافه في هذا
البرنامج
هذه لحظات حاسمه للغايه بالنسبه الينا
وينبغي ان نتذكر ان بولندا تقع في بيئه
جغرافيه خطيره وهو وضع استمر لعقود من
الزمن
وبولندا تقع على ممرات مهمه بين الشرق
والغرب وهو امر مفيد للتجاره الدوليه لكنه
لا يخدم المصالح الامنيه
بولندا تقع كذلك على حدود بلد تعرض للهجوم
وهي البلد الاوروبي الوحيد الذي يعيش في
هذه البيئه الجغرافيه وبولندا لديها ايضا
بلد جار صعب للغايه لذلك ينبغي ان نبذل
قصار جهودنا من اجل تحسين اوضاعنا الامنيه
[موسيقى]
فيما يتعلق بالصفقات العسكريه مؤخرا اجرت
بولندا وقامت بالتوقيع على عدد كبير من
الصفقات العسكريه لكن الى اي مدى هذه
الصفقات تلبي الاحتياجات الفعليه للجيش
البولندي في هذه المرحله
[موسيقى]
ما تتساءل عنه الجيوش دائما هو ما الحجم
من حيث العدد والمعدات التي يمكن اعتبارها
كافيه بالنسبه اليها
لا سيما فيما يخص عدد الدبابات والطائرات
وغير ذلك وبالنسبه للاعتبارات الامنيه
فاننا نتعامل مع وضع يتميز بالصعوبه وهو
غير واضح المعالم في جميع الاحوال لكن
الحرب التي تدور راحاها في جوارنا تتسبب
في تسريع الكثير من البرامج الدفاعيه
لدينا ويسري هذا التسريع على شتى المجالات
وبكل بساطه ليس لدينا الوقت الذي يسمح لنا
بتبني نهج يتسم بالبطء بغيه بلوغ اهدافنا
في ظل استمرار هذه الحرب التي تجعلنا نسرع
الخطى حتى نكون جاهزين لمواجهه الاوضاع
الصعبه السائده وفي الوقت ذاته فان الدعم
واسع النطاق الذي نقدمه لاوكرانيا والذي
شمل على سبيل المثال مدها بنحو ثلاثمائه
دبابه يستوجب استبدال هذه المعدات
العسكريه باخرى جديده لذلك يتعين علينا ان
نبحث في اطار برنامج التحديث الذي يخضع له
جيشنا عن السبل الكفيله بتمكيننا من
الحصول على الذخائر والطائرات والدبابات
وغيرها من المعدات العسكريه التي نزود
اوكرانيا بها
وبطبيعه الحال هذه فرصه فريده من نوعها
تتاح لنا للتخلص من العتاد العسكري الذي
يعود الى الحقبه السوفييتيه والذي لا يزال
موجودا لدينا
وربما يسمح لنا هذا الامر بتحقيق قفزه
نوعيه لكن برنامج تحديث القوات المسلحه في
بولندا هو برنامج ضخم ولدينا لائحه
مشتريات العسكريه ضخمه في الوقت الراهن
لكن الملاحظه جنرال في الكاوسكي واعنيك
كما تفضلت بانه الكثير من هذه الصفقات هي
صفقات لاسلحه بنيت على عقيده غربيه سواء
اسلحه اوروبيه او حتى اسلحه امريكيه
السؤال في هذا الاطار الى اي مدى الجندي
في بولندا والمقاتل في بولندا مستعد
للتعامل مع هذه المعدات ومع هذه الاسلحه
خاصه بانه لديه تاريخ في التعامل مع معدات
كما ذكرت معدات سوفيتيه بالكامل
ان الاسلحه التي تحتاج اليها بولندا لا
تصلها بالطبع بين عشيه وضحاها بل يتم
تسليمها على المدى القريب والمتوسط
والبعيد بالنظر الى تلبيه متطلبات التدريب
والاحتياجات اللوجستيه الاخرى
على سبيل المثال لن نحصل على 250 دبابه
ابرامز دفعه واحده وانما سوف يتم تسليم
هذه الدبابات الى بولندا على دفعات وينبغي
الاشاره ايضا الى ان السلطات بلادنا قد
قررت زياده عدد افراد قواتنا المسلحه من
نحو 150 الفا الى ثلاثمائه الف جندي كما
سيتم انشاء اقسام اخرى في اطار برنامج
التحديث علاوه على ذلك شهدت ميزانيه
الدفاع في بولندا زياده والخطه الاساسيه
كانت ترتكز على مقاربه تدريجيه بدءا
بزياده الميزانيه لنحو اثنين في المئه من
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي وهي النسبه التي
تم تحديدها من قبل حلف الناتو لكننا نرغب
في تحقيق زياده في ميزانيه الدفاع تصل الى
ثلاثه في المئه من الناتج المحلي وهي
زياده هائله وهذه كلها تطورات ناجمه عن
الاحداث التي نشهدها حاليا ونظرا لان
متطلبات الامن لا تقع فقط على كاهل الجيش
وانما يطلع بها الجميع في بولندا فاننا
نعمل على التكيف مع الاوضاع السائده باسرع
ما يمكن وقد ابرمنا صفقه لشراء اثنتين
وثلاثين طائره من طراز 35 وسوف نسلم
اوكرانيا 20 طائره من طراز 29 كما وقعنا
عقدا لشراء خمسه واربعين طائره حربيه من
كوريا الجنوبيه واشترينا طائرات مسيره من
طراز بيرقدار من تركيا ونستخدم ايضا
طائرات مسيره حصلنا عليها من الولايات
المتحده
ووقعنا كذلك عقدا لشراء قمرين صناعيين
فرنسيين الى جانب عقد اخر لشراء منظومه
راجمات صواريخ ونحو الف دبابه من كوريا
الجنوبيه هذا جهد جبار يبذل في اطار تحديث
الجيش البولندي
صوت
جنرال كوفسكي في بدايه حديثك تحدثت عن
البيئه الجغرافيه والدول المحيطه في
بولندا ووصفت بانها في موقع جغرافي صعب
وتحدثت عن بيلاروسيا مؤخرا اعلنت موسكو
نشر قنابل تكتيكيه في بيلاروسيا نوويه
اولا كيف ترى هذه الخطوه وهل هذا سيدفع
حلف الناتو لنشر اسلحه نوويه في بولندا في
المستقبل القريب وما هو موقف بولندا كذلك
في هذا الاطار
بالنسبه للموقف البولندي هذا سؤال يوجه
الى السلطات البولنديه فما انا سوى جنرال
متقاعد ولا يسعني سوى التكهن بشان هذا
الامر لكن ما استطيع قوله هو ان روسيا
تتعمد زياده مخاطر استخدام الاسلحه
النوويه وهذه السرديه ترددت كثيرا الحرب
البارده لان كل الاطراف كانت تثير مساله
اللجوء الى الاسلحه النوويه لكنها لم تكن
تتقاتل فيما بينها كما لم يكن بمقدور احد
ان يدرك ما يمكن ان تؤول اليه التهديدات
اما بالنسبه لما نشهده حاليا فان التهديد
باستخدام الاسلحه النوويه تكرر اكثر من
مره وهو امر غايه في الخطوره غير ان خبراء
كثرا يعتقدون ان خطر استخدام الاسلحه
النوويه ضئيل جدا ولا يتجاوز نسبه خمسه في
المئه وفقا لمقال طلعت عليه وروسيا قررت
الان ان تشمل معادلتها النوويه بلدنا
الجار بيلاروسيا وهو امر خطير للغايه الا
انني لا اعتقد ان بيلاروسيا ببقدورها
اتخاذ قرار من هذا القبيل لان روسيا هي من
لها الكلمه الفصل روسيا
تحث خطاها وتستخدم خطاب الحرب البارده
الجديده او الحرب العالميه الجديده بغيت
التهديد والترويع ودفع بلدان ليس لديها
الرغبه في الانضمام الى فضاء النفوذ
الروسي